blanco de los ataques en la oscuridad de
la noche al bastión ruso en la región
del dumbas está en alerta los edificios
de apartamentos fueron incendiados
Incluso el centro de la ciudad está
afectado
las calles de la urbe controlada desde
hace ocho años por los separatistas
prorusos están casi desiertas Desde hace
dos semanas los ataques aumentaron
nunca ha estado tan mal nunca durante
estos nueve meses de guerra nunca nos
han golpeado tanto como ahora
el sonido de la artillería rusa puede
oírse en toda la ciudad pero aunque
Kevin la comunidad internacional
consideran que doc siempre ha formado
parte del país sus residentes temen los
ataques ucranianos
quien dispara los valientes ucranianos
[Música]
nuestro país está en guerra con su
propio país es incomprensible porque
luchan
en esta casa un cohete atravesó el
tejado y luego la pared algo que
sorprendió a sus residentes no tengo
casa no tengo a dónde ir no tengo nada
se acabó soy una mujer vieja enferma y
destruida desde principios de mes 36
civiles han muerto en la región de
domíes según los rusos acusan a la otan
que suministra las armas esto también se
hace en Estados Unidos
La amenaza también viene del interior
del territorio que controlan los rusos
una explosión dañó este puente situado
en la carretera entre el dumbas y crimea
ataques como estos forman parte de la
estrategia actual de Ucrania impedir y
debilitar el abastecimiento de las
fuerzas rusas